croise les doigts sans pour
roire au miracle.
- À qier,
la ministre des Transports
est venue voir ce qui ronge
le tunnel et force cet immense
chantier. Mais après avoir
salué le travail des quelque
e 22 heuree 22 heuree 22 heuree,
l'essentiel des messages était
destiné aux automo
GENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT, ministre
Transports et Mobilité durable
- Ça va être très corsé à parti
semblant qu'il y a une solution
miraculeuse à portée de main qui
va nous apparaître. Je pense que
la solution, elle réside dans la
somme des gestes et des actions
- Elle incite en particulier
à utiliser le transport ennsporn
commun, demande aux employeurs
de maximiser le télétravailrairs
que le 9 à 5, mais aussi
d'ajuster les horaires
de livraison.de bannir l'auto
solo à l'heure de pointe...
- On n'est pas en ce moment
à un stade où on veut interdire.
On est dans la très forte
recommandation.
- Aux abord de l'autoroute,yenst
une invasion de véhicules da
leurs rues. Ils réclament plus
d'information de la part du MTQ
la qualité de leur air.
JACQUES LAURIN, Collectif
en environnement Mercier-Est
- Il y aurait peut-être
illonage soit localisée
en bordure de l'A-25.
- L'inte- L'inte- L'inte- L'inte
la circulation dans le secteur
tient au fait qu'une seule voie,
une décision qui s'imposait,sel.
GENEVIÈVE CAMPEAU, ingénieure et
directrice mobilité, Intervia
nos simulations pour voir un peu
à qui on va donner les deuxr lex
voies, on voyait qu'en donnant
une voie en direction Montréal,
des temps de parcours en tunnel
qui deveaisonnables.
Vous ne voulez pas être pris
30 minutes dans le tunnel,
- Depuis cette semaine,
la confieux voies vers
Montréal est déjà en vigueur.
Résultat aux abords du pont-
lors des simulations,
nous dit l'entrepr l'entrepr l',
mais le véritable verdict sera
rendu par les autola semaine pr.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, Mon